[Applause]
so you're playing an awesome
kick-ass queer superhero what does it
mean to you to be able to represent for
the lgbtq plus community like that i'm
just so proud i think it's really
important for you know especially that
certain group of people to feel
represented since i don't think they're
um represented enough yes she's marvel's
first latin american lgbtq plus
character to start in an ongoing comic
book series now america chavez is ready
to make her live-action debut what's
important is that that's exactly what
marvel
does so well they they voice the
voiceless and to have such a huge
platform to give those opportunities you
know we create things like shanghai we
have miss marvel moon night it's very
far-reaching
now such i wanna i wanna say like what
an mcu entrance like this is wild can
you describe for me the feeling that you
got in your stomach the first time you
saw yourself on screen with the
benedict's there i remember one of our
first scenes that we shot together i was
so nervous i was like oh my gosh but
definitely watching playback it really
became real it was just like wow i'm
really in this and then of course seeing
the posters it's like it's one thing to
be in the movie but sometimes you know
you don't really make it on the poster
i made it on the poster yeah her scale
size is even bigger than my biggest
poster size it's uh
you all remember the infinity war uh
size there i still never let them
live that down